so there's been a lot of leaking from
the doj recently but somehow the justice
department has not leaked anything
really about jeffrey epstein including
his client list
why is that well elon musk a big picture
man if there ever was one asked that
question recently quote the only thing
more remarkable than dog not leaking the
list is that no one in the media cares
he wrote well that's true
and while we're on the topic of epstein
why did bruce reinhardt the magistrate
judge who approved the mar-a-lago raid
represent several of jeffrey epstein's
employees including his pilot and his
schedule
ah weird
bobby capucci is a podcast host who is
doggedly following this story he joins
us tonight bobby thanks so much for
coming on so you follow this full-time
one of the few does why haven't
we gotten any of this information in the
form of leaks to the new york times do
you think
well in my opinion it has to do with how
far it goes this is such a
gigantic in scope operation that he was
running that if they really dug deep
that it would be
almost
earth-shattering what they would
discover if you take a look at some of
the similar cases in new york at a
similar time for similar crimes r kelly
or keith ranieri both were hit with rico
charges but epstein maxwell no rico
there
i wonder why
yeah it's kind of weird i mean they they
grabbed some alex jones's text the other
day and the line is that alex jones is
the real criminal not jeffrey epstein
right but the second they got his texts
you know you you know everything
everything embarrassing thing he's ever
said of course is give me the new york
times but they are affirmatively
protecting jeffrey epstein who's not
even alive
anymore i just i it's one of the
weirdest things i've ever seen
it's been going on all the way since the
vanity fair article back in 2002 the
puff piece on on jeffrey epstein back
then you know maria farmer outed this
guy in 1995 1996 nobody followed up on
it nobody ever pursued him the way they
should have and it was all happening
right under the nose of the sdny who
loves to get on their ivory tower and
preach down to the rest of us on a
regular basis about how bad we live our
lives meanwhile this guy was running
around in their district for
four presidencies hanging out at the
white house you know they're all of it
and nobody cares what's going on until
the survivors themselves decide to go
and take the case to the people and we
see what's happened since then there's
been an avalanche effect and they've had
to react to it
really quick you keep reading
suggestions that there is a trove of
videotape of other people at epstein's
properties do you think that's true
well what i can tell you is
all of the survivors who had access to
his townhouse all of them that had
access to palm beach they all said that
there were surveillance rooms in those
houses set up for that specific purpose
to take video of everybody who came in
and to document it so we're talking
about the people that actually lived
through this telling us that and nobody
cares we have i mean when the daily mail
is leading the charge to go after
somebody like prince andrew and not the
gray lady or the washington post that
tells you everything you need to know
about where the legacy media is at
that's exactly right and of course he
was connected to various intelligence
agencies which might be the real answer
bobby i appreciate your staying on the
story when few others are thanks a lot
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight